okay I am going to present hatred mail
to you today but if you've never heard
of or heard hatred mail before here's an
explanation of what that is the right of
the people to keep and bear hates shall
not be infringed patriot man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America because freedom all right so I
do want to warn you this is a really
aggressive in harsh patriot mail and
sometimes people email me and they say
David you know why aren't you censoring
hatred mail more because we're on
broadcast radio and TV in hatred mail we
censor what we are bound to censor by
the FCC because we don't want to get
fined or get any of our broadcast
affiliates fined but beyond that we
don't censor this is what we deal with
day in and day out for producing this
program thousands of messages like this
pour in every month okay
so this is just one example it is very
harsh and aggressive let's take a listen
to it
damn this typical [ __ ] offense Pakman
thinks we care about his opinions i
clicked here to comment only not watch
this is what is really happening as was
said in vietnam inside every [ __ ] is a
white american trying to get outside as
was said in detroit inside every nagger
is a criminal trying to get outside and
as Rothschild joked with Hitler inside
of every liberal Jew is a [ __ ]
squealing anti-semite trying to get out
Jews did 9/11 don't forget i like how
after this entire tirade of insults he
throws and by the way Jews did 9/11 I
don't want to I don't want to end this
before throwing that in there as well
this level of vitriol Rachel it can't be
healthy right if you walk around
believing this type of thing with this
level of anger I almost feel bad for the
person because clearly something has
gone very wrong in your life that you
have these feelings towards basically
every minority group I mean the guy just
checked almost every box here
yeah it kind of looked like he just went
through a list of every kind of
offensive derogatory term and just
thought okay how can i construct these
in a string of sentences and then put
them together and then put them out on
the internet I wouldn't even consider I
barely think to write to any program i
watch the idea of writing something this
vile and and retrograde and depraved I
can't even imagine what is going on in
this individuals life but as always you
can turn hate reott mail into something
positive if you sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership you
can use coupon code hay tree at 40 and
that will get you a nice discount off of
membership